[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في مجلس الانباء من
قناه الجزيره اعتقل مكتب والتحقيقات
الفيدراليه المشتبه في تسريبه وثائق
البنتاجون وهو جاك تشيره احد افراد الحرس
الوطني الجوي في مسره
وقالت وسائل اعلام الامريكيه اختصاصي
بتقنيه المعلومات استخبارات الحرس الوطني
قادر المتحدث باسم البنتاجون الى الوثائق
التي اصربت حساسه وانما حدث جريمه متعمده
ورفض المتحدث مناقشه تفاصيل الوثائق
المسربه بسبب حساسيتها وتاثيرها على الامن
القومي لكنه اقر بخطوره التسريب على
علاقات الولايات المتحده مع حلفائها اتهم
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع بحشد قوات
داخل العاصمه وبعض المدن وحذر من منعطف
خطير تمر به البلاد وقال مصدرهم في الجيش
في الجزيره ان قوات الدعم السريع
ادخلت ناقلات جند الى العاصمه نقلت من
شمالي دارفور وقد اكد محمد حمدان حميدتين
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده للمبعوثين
الامريكيه والبريطاني والنرويجي حرصه على
تعزيز الاستقرار ودعم مسيره التحول
الديمقراطي
وقد اعرب المبعوثون والممثلون الخاصون من
فرنسا والمانيا ونرويج وبريطانيا
والولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
اعربوا عن قلقهم البالغ ازاء التصعيد بين
القوات السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريان
ودعا المبعوثون القاده العسكريين
والمدنيين لاتخاذ خطوات فعاله لخفض
التصعيد
دعا مفوض السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيفوري الى ضروره تخفيف حده
التوتر في مضيق التايوان وقال ان اي تغيير
في الوضع الراهن بالقوه سيكون غير مقبول
وراى بوريل في نص خطاب كان سيلقيه العاصمه
بجين ان الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يرى في صعود
الصين امرا مخيفا
اجرى الجيش الصيني ومناورات صاروخيه
بالذخيره الحيه في اقليم تشينج غربيه
البلاد وعرضت وسائل الاعلام الصينيه صورا
قالت انها لتلك المناورات دون ذكر
التفاصيل او تحديد تاريخ اجرائها
اختبرت كوريا الشماليه صاروخا باليسيا
عابرا للقارات يعمل بالوقود الصلب وقالوا
على كوريا الشماليه ان الزعيم البلاد اشرف
بنفسه على عمليه اختبار الصاروخ
اندلعت مواجهتهم في العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس بين الشرطه ومتظاهرين رافضين لقانون
التقاعد الجديد والتظاهر رافضون لرفع سن
التقاعد الى 64 عاما في مدن فرنسيه عده
تلبيه لدعوه النقابات العماليه استباقا
لقرار مرتقب من المجلس الدستوري بشان
تعديل قانون التقاعد وطلب نوابهم من
المجلس الدستوريه السماح باستفتاء عاد
المبادره المشتركه للاصلاح المعاشات
مشاهدينا شكرا لكم واينما كنتم
[موسيقى]